bruce hearson says i just rewatched the
original star wars and i have a question
how did luke get authorization to pilot
an x-wing solely on his own claim
to being a great pilot and that of a
single random aussie
well it's not just his own claim biggs
dark lighter says that
luke is the best bush pilot in the outer
rim no question
the incom t65 x-wing is made by the same
manufacturer as
luke's t-16 back home the controls were
said to be
nearly identical so if you know how to
fly a t-16 you should know how to fly a
t-65 also they were just desperate and
they needed everyone they could get
they just lost their last red five at
the battle of scarif
someone get in that cockpit so yeah
close enough
for the rebels hi i'm alex damon and i'm
molly damon
and this is star wars support part two
[Music]
at sadistic samurai says i have a star
wars question for those who follow star
wars that's us
the stormtroopers in the original
trilogy signed up for it like joining
the army they aren't clones like in the
second trilogy or child soldiers like in
the new trilogy
correct they are not clones the clones
got phased out
in between episodes three and four
they were kind of a mixture of yes
people who
believed in the empire and signed up
occasionally they were also
conscripts so people forced into the
army but no they weren't
kidnapped child soldiers the way that
they were
in the first order it's really a good
example of how
the empire kind of brainwashed the
general public because we see an
in the new hope how badly luke wants to
go off to the imperial academy
yeah that's a good point like a lot of
people it was just kind of
the only escape route like luke didn't
like the empire but to get off a
tatooine he had no other choice
but to join the imperial academy at my
name is vador
i have a question for you who is your
favorite character from star wars
legends hashtag star wars hashtag star
wars legends
star wars legends refers to all of the
star wars storytelling that was
basically before
the disney acquisition so it's what used
to be known as the star wars eu
books and comics and then the movies
started to come back out with the
prequels and
honestly george lucas kind of changed a
lot of stuff and so the the eu tried to
adapt
to make it all still work but yeah
basically
anything that was prior to 2014 or so
got classified as star wars legends and
is no longer part of the canon
i jokingly say gavin dark lighter a lot
because if biggs couldn't survive i love
seeing his cousin pop in and he is a
great pilot
i do love pilots and i also love the
legends version of
wedge antilles just because he so far
has gotten to do a whole lot more
in legends than he has in canon i'm a
big sucker for pilots
i'll go with one that's probably a lot
of people's answer
and say mara jade just cause i can't get
enough
of awesome female jedi and i i love
how her story starts with her being the
emperor's hand
evil then turns to a good guy i think
it's pretty cool plus she's got a purple
lightsaber
and red hair yeah i am mary jane
black lives matter says question star
wars stands i want to start the
mandalorian but i really don't know much
about star wars like y'all
so is it mad connected to the films or
can i just watch it as a standalone
like is it hard to follow otherwise i
think they did a pretty good job of
letting that be an entry point into the
galaxy
yeah i this is one of the things i love
the most
about the mandalorian is that normies
as we might say or people who haven't
seen a lot of star wars
i think would love the show and there's
little bits and pieces
in the show for nerds like us to get
excited about
but you really don't have to have seen
any of the movies or tv shows
to enjoy the mandalorian i agree i think
that anything that is connected to other
material is well explained
and if anything it might make you more
interested in some of those other star
wars
stories uh that you could dive into mira
jade's publicist
says honest question why does everyone
in this star wars universe know
every sub-clause of the mandalorian
creed but no one remembers the jedi
on this planet we're still talking about
the knights of the round table
that's funny that's a good point i don't
think that there was like a
massive smear campaign against the
knights of the round table to hide their
history
and even then like i don't know the
truth of the knights of the round table
i've mostly heard legends and stories
which i would say
probably most people don't know the
truth of the jedi in the star wars
universe
i do think it's so you're right everyone
seems to know like aren't you a
mandalorian aren't you supposed to do
this or this or this
with the finger wag too yeah i guess
even though the mandalorians have
significantly decreased in their number
thanks to the great purge
they still are around to some extent
they still
seem to be known the jedi were
completely wiped out
also i think that it's hard to kind of
keep this in perspective but the jedi
at their height numbered about 10 000
people in a galaxy of
trillions so not that many people really
ever met
a jedi mandalorians numbered more
there were more mandalorians than just
ten thousand so
i think that they were probably just
more prevalent in the galaxy
even when the jedi were at their height
i'd say also just on a very basic level
uh for instance when denjarin
goes into the bar and is looking for
other mandalorians
he basically says someone who looks like
me so
they're pretty recognizable at abby simp
hours
says so i have a lore question for my
star wars moots
has the idea of the jedi supposedly
rebelling against the republic
ever been explored or palpatine's use of
retroactive history to sully the jedi
have there been people who hate distrust
the idea of jedi because of this
uh yes they haven't done a whole lot
with it
it's mostly in the books a little bit in
the comics
in charles soule's darth vader comic
like right after revenge of the sith
everyone seemed to be pretty pleased
that the jedi were killed off they
seemed to have bought into the lie that
the jedi rebelled against the republic
and tried to assassinate the chancellor
wasn't explored a little bit in season
seven of
clone wars like when ahsoka is kind of
out in the world
she isn't telling people outwardly that
she's a jedi
and then once the two sisters find out
that she is
they're like oh jedi are nothing but
trouble we don't want your help
yes i would that's absolutely laying the
groundwork for why people so easily were
like
yeah forget the jedi and i think you can
see that in the films too i mean
only 20 years later no one seems to know
who the jedi were
palpatine was doing his best to just
snuff out any mention of them
people were pretty quick to forget who
they were
at mrs yuen says okay here's a star wars
question
with palpatine being revealed in episode
9 and revealed that snoke was a clone
doesn't that break the sith rule of two
since snoke was in technical sense
palpatine's apprentice and snoke had
kylo as an apprentice
that means there were three sith oh boy
um
the rule of two is this sith philosophy
that there can only be two at any given
time
in legends it was set up by darth bane
which is still true in canon but
there were a bunch of sith at one point
and darth bane was like we're not
getting anywhere because we keep
fighting with each other
so he was like okay here's how we fix
this i'm gonna kill
everybody except for myself and then i'm
going to take an apprentice and train
them
teach them everything i know until
they're strong enough to
kill me then they're going to take an
apprentice and do the same thing and in
that way
the sith will only get stronger and
stronger and they'll be living in secret
instead of just taking things by brute
force they're gonna do basically what
palpatine did
and rise politically and take power that
way so
snoke and kylo ren are not sith
they do not follow sith teachings but
that said
palpatine has never really been a
stickler for the rules
yeah he seemed to have like one
apprentice at a time but then that
apprentice would have another apprentice
that palpatine would know about and he's
like uh whatever
yeah palpatine had maul as his
apprentice he didn't work out
gave him the boot then he had count
dooku as his apprentice
found out dooku had ventress got mad at
dooku
told him to kill her palpatine
was kind of the culmination of the sith
rule of two and i think that in his mind
he was like
it's not gonna go on without me he
wanted to be
the culmination of the sith forever it's
they're really bad at following their
own rule
yeah at does art 72 says question for
school
do you think the rebel alliance of star
wars is a good example of desperation
forcing others to adapt and survive i
feel like it is because
while the empire had vastly superior
numbers and weapons
the rebels had a reason to fight and
managed to pull off the battle of scarif
yavin endor jakku and a bunch of others
yes i feel like that's exactly what
george lucas has said
that the rebels were supposed to
represent
the scrappy group of underdogs coming up
to win against the
technologically superior force that was
supposed to win it's just like the
vietnam war the american revolutionary
war
it's happened a ton of times in history
yeah it's it's the idea
of the good guys always have a better
reason to fight
they have hope on their side as
star wars loves to say yeah i think that
that's a perfect
description of how that works let's talk
max mercury
asks a question from my star wars moots
do we think that the mandalorian is set
before or after the battle of jakku
they sound like they're keeping it a
little vague on purpose so they can be
flexible but
the initial estimates uh john favreau
said that it takes place about five
years after return of the jedi
which means that would be four years
after the battle of jakku
i think that there's room for them to
mix it up but
the new republic is pretty much
established at this point in the show
i think it's well beyond the battle of
jakku the mechanic at coms open
says star wars fans quick question is
the clone wars
movie just a sum up of the series or did
it happen
before also rebels is after the clone
wars and i saw someone made an order to
watch the episodes
but isn't it watchable normally
oh boy lots of unpack real quick the
clone wars movie
is basically just two or three episodes
of the clone wars crammed into a movie
and so it doesn't sum up the entire
series it also didn't really happen
before the series
it happens like four episodes into the
series
as you said someone made an order to
watch the epps you can watch it
as it's listed on disney plus but there
is a chronological episode
list because the series is very much out
of order yeah you can find that list on
starwars.com
i prefer chronological i would watch it
chronologically yeah i think i would too
because it just makes more sense it's a
little bit of a hassle because you have
to like
check the list and you're going gonna
have to change episodes it gets to be
more chronological after the first like
two seasons
you're not bouncing around as much yeah
i'd say
the most important thing about the clone
wars movie
is it introduces ahsoka
into the story yes rebels is after the
clone wars yeah rebels takes place
after clone wars neil rhombus says
serious question
if the jedi are so strong why are there
so few of them
and why are they always trying to
rebuild the jedi order
i think a lot of people think that the
force makes
jedi just like super powerful all the
time they're superheroes and they can do
anything they want
being a jedi accessing the force it's
not something you can just turn
on and off like everyone has good days
and bad days
in the real world the same is true for
the jedi it's more a mental thing of
like how
balanced are you how connected to the
universe
are you how compassionate are you to the
people around you
it's not something that it's just all
the time i'm pulling star destroyers out
of the sky
yeah i wouldn't even say that the jedi
are that strong there are a
few select jedi that are pretty strong
in the force but
overall it's a fair assumption to make
though i never
fault anyone for acting like that's the
case because i mean like the comics
and uh some of the a lot of legends
material
the video games the video games yeah i
mean the video games are video games
they want you to feel like you can do
anything with the force
but what george lucas has said what the
movies have said
is that it's more about like keeping a
mental balance within yourself
around the galaxy says question for my
canon friends
was the maw installation from the
legends novel jedi search which also
features
kessel the inspiration for slash related
to the maw and
solo a star wars story i would say
probably
like can't say for sure but solo had so
many little legends
easter eggs in it that yeah i think they
were like
ah let's throw the maw in there
it's a little different at least the way
we see it in legends it was like
a bunch of black holes near each other
and solo it's like just one big black
hole
yeah i don't think they would name it
the maw unless they were trying to make
that little connection
yeah i do think it's cool that after
looking into so much trivia about all of
the movies and tv shows that the maul
is not the monster a lot of people kind
of got those two confused the
the monster that attacks them and then
gets sucked into the maw
is the summa vermin uh-huh that's even
even han goes is that the maw
yeah and it's like nope that that big
black hole sucking that into it is the
mall
mark's forever mandalorian says here's a
question for you does order 66
trigger the kill instinct for only jedi
or any nearby force users not
named palpatine or skywalker i've made
this joke before
but i like to think that palpatine
basically had like a google doc
that he was adding and subtracting names
to
so at first he has like all the jedi on
this spreadsheet
and then if he starts to think like oh
there's uh
someone i think i could get to be an
inquisitor i'll just take them out of
there and like oh well i think anakin is
probably gonna be my apprentice i'll
just
move him off the list yeah and then
anyone who maybe
owed him money added to the list like
yep this person's a jedi
this person's definitely a jedi just
take them out too
i like that but but yeah also like
ahsoka it's not like she leaves the jedi
order and he's gonna be like oh well i
guess she's safe now yeah like nah
the supreme jedi says question why
didn't rey's body disappear when she
died
what the force and jedi's stuff say
about this
what's the theory so this is a another
hard one to talk about because
vader's body didn't die or disappear
when he died but he still became a force
ghost and that's like a whole big thing
where you're supposed to like
go through specific training to become a
force ghost but anakin also didn't
go through that so why is he allowed to
be a force ghost at all
um i don't think ben went through that
training so in my mind i like to think
of it as
them being a jedi how they died if they
died doing
something that was like funneling them
into the force like become
basically yeah becoming one with the
force obi-wan
kind of does it in a very brief moment
on the death star
he kind of like backs off and he's like
okay my
job is done i put luke and lay together
ben kind of
does it by funneling his life force to
save rey
luke dies or fades away shortly after
doing the big force sacrifice
i i do think that there's something to
that i would say that they are like
becoming one with the force i think that
obi-wan i mean he knew
he like closes his eyes he's preparing i
don't know
if he died because vader hit him with a
saber or if he just
chose to become one with the force yoda
knew that he was old and sick and he may
have just
said like okay i'm gonna become one with
the force now same with luke
and i think that it's possible that ben
was like i'm going to give
rey my life force and i will become one
with the force he knew
that he was going to die doing that so
yeah i think that there's something to
that
ray maybe didn't have that intent
i could also say that maybe she didn't
disappear because
the force like the cosmic force knew
like okay hold on
we know something's about to happen like
leave her body
yeah i like that theory the idea that
she didn't automatically disappear
because
let's say the wills uh just knew
okay ben is going to do the right thing
finally
um and save rey so
yeah at overlord mikey says i just
thought about this but if the baby yoda
creature is over 50 years old how old is
yoda supposed to be
how do you live that long and never
question jedi teachings which i'd like
to point out are incredibly unhealthy
and messed up
guess they just had a long time to
brainwash him so yeah yoda is supposed
to be
900 years old when he dies i do think
they're going to
talk about this i don't know how he
relates to jedi teachings because he's
going to be in the high republic era
it sounds like the jedi are going to be
very different
200 years prior to like the prequels and
everything so i think we're gonna
get to see maybe yoda's mindset change
over that period of time yeah i've said
it before but i hope
the yoda that we see in the high
republic is like
bad boy yoda just you know
sticking it to the man questioning
everything
i don't i don't think that'll happen but
that would be my dream
i think he'll be different brian c wood
says i have a star wars question i don't
think anyone has ever asked if a funeral
pyre is the traditional jedi funeral
then how long do the mourners stand
around the pyre and what happens to the
ashes
are they stored someplace and who
collects them temple monks
i don't know how long everyone has to
stand around and respectfully watch
a body burn maybe that is up to
the jedi and how great their deeds were
i assumed the ashes would be taken back
to the
uh jedi temple in the case of vader you
know
luke didn't stick around for long and we
know that vader's mask
got picked up yeah it sounds like luke
just kind of
set it on fire and like watched for a
second was like all right i'm going to
the party
but we also know that funeral pyre
wasn't the only way
that jedi funerals happened like jedha
there there were tombs there there were
a bunch of different alternatives so
maybe qui-gon just had in his will
like uh funeral prior please yeah we
talked recently about whether or not
jedi's had wills and
and i i think that that's plausible
the lady of the lake says a question
about the rise of skywalker i have
is was snoke like a meat puppet that
palpatine used via the force
or was he his own living breathing
entity that was just being manipulated
or was he a clone grown poorly well i
think
you could argue that he's all of these
things
[Laughter]
yeah that's kind of true so palpatine
does claim to be every voice
that ben solo has ever heard inside his
head
i don't think that snoke was strictly a
meat puppet
i do think that he had free will so to
speak i don't think he was aware
of who or what he was but from what i've
gathered i think palpatine put in
he was basically a programmed person of
saying like here's where you come from
here's what your goals are
uh you need to train this kid like
seduce him to the dark side
bring him over uh and then train him see
he basically had a pre-loaded
disposition yeah i don't think he had
free wills so to speak but
also i don't think he was just
constantly
controlled in that same scene palpatine
does say like snoke trained you well
i i don't know it can go either way
frankly but that's just
my best guess do you think that
palpatine purposefully
made him to look mangled and scarred
so that kylo would think that luke did
that to him
there's a comic the rise of kylo ren and
he meets up with snoke and says what did
master luke do to you
which suggests that snoke didn't always
look that way
but then why is there a vat of those
clones in the rise of skywalker looking
already messed up i don't know i think
that was maybe a
palpatine on purpose thing i think maybe
he
wanted another like gross looking person
to
hang out with so he wasn't the only one
thank you
so much for your questions they were
great there were some
funny ones there were some questions
that i had never even thought of before
so i we we always love when we're
surprised by star wars questions
we talk about star wars basically every
day and
we're still learning new things and it's
fantastic
to see so many people so interested
still in the franchise yeah so thank you
again and this has been
star wars support